there and back to Franco's okay no this
this is wild dude so he signed man and
and you know it's actually really
interesting about it is you know I'm
sure Frank Ocean fans kind of know this
story but it's a good testament not good
testament but it's another great example
of [ __ ] the internet man how it's
changed music so I guess Frank was
signed by the student him tricky I think
that's his name and he's like he is a
managers and um tricky was a producer
and I think he worked for Def Jam okay
and he got I think he got Frank signed
to Def Jam okay and tricky was response
Frank was independent that it's like
always been his thing so that's like
that's what's kind of cool okay all
right so he gets signed a Def Jam and um
a tricky hit he produced Baby by Justin
Bieber you can do single ladies yeah
absolutely bang yeah he's like you know
he produced umbrella so it's like he's
got yeah
hit hit factory so he got you know we
got Frank sign but then Def Jam just
kind of went silent and they put him on
the shelf and they weren't really
excited about Frank like they didn't see
the magic okay so Frank you know at that
time was doing a lot with Oh F and he's
like all right he's like [ __ ] y'all
muhfuckas so he came out with um uh
orange channel not sure that was after a
nostalgia ultra or whatever okay
who's a mixtape you put it out as a
mixtape and that had like you know I
like swim good no no no swim good [ __ ]
I'm [ __ ] this all up anyway he had to
[ __ ] big ass songs on there like
underground hits and then all of a
sudden Def Jam is like oh you're an
artist
so they took those two songs they blew
him up they shot music videos for own
cool then for channel orange this is
like 2012 ish Frank goes alright I want
a million dollars I want full creative
control that it out they're like yeah
sure
so they give it to him and
[Music]
the hell well so then then he comes out
with a channel orange okay and it does
amazing right and then now I guess his
deal was that he had a third album so
things like a you know two or three
album thing or whatever so he's in his
deal he wants out he and and so he
starts like kind of this chess match
with Def Jam and he starts like you know
he releases a snippet and like he's kind
of delaying the release of the album and
like a long period passes until do you
member when he did that livestream yep
so this is the craziest [ __ ] is the
craziest like finesse I guess so and
shouts this dude he did a video on it
trapped Lord something I don't know you
got to look at okay I'm tired today guys
I'm sorry he kind of put this
information together but basically Frank
did that livestream was like a hundred
of 40 hours long and it built up into
that album endless which was like an
exclusive between Def Jam and Apple
music and I guess he got paid 20 mil for
it but what it was was that the
livestream played an album technically
so it technically finished his deal and
what it really was was a gigantic
[ __ ] arrow to blonde which was it was
an independent release and he dropped it
the day after he put out endless I
remember that yeah yeah I read an
article about this too yeah I think yeah
right after it happened because people
were like holy [ __ ] mm-hmm this is a
crazy finesse yeah yeah so was the live
stream all original music yeah it was
two people so listen to that I don't
know so that's the thing I didn't get a
chance to look up afterward but I guess
ASAP Rocky on a radio interview was
talking about how to a yo Frank pulled
off the greatest finesse on Def Jam and
no one talks about it and this dude
basically dug up that after that the Def
Jam CEO was like no more streaming
exclusive
uh Draycott 20 mil someone else got 20
mils so you could assume Frank probably
got in that range and then after that
he's like yeah we're not doing that
anymore cuz he [ __ ] him over cuz he
cuz it cuz once he got the money it was
like it wasn't it was just like a
straight-up payment like okay we'll pay
you to have exclusive rights to this
album okay you know and he goes cool
I'll take the 20 million I'll do this
live stream it's gonna be really weird
and artistic and what what is this
streaming exclusive so that that whole
thing you can only find on Apple music
his the endless album gotcha and on it's
still on there yeah
Otis yeah okay the dude said that the
only other place he could find it was
porn of which yeah of course it can find
anything there yeah I mean yeah so yeah
it's and then and then he did blonde
independent and blonde got [ __ ] you
know did numbers and endless did like
next to nothing
I guess he said for the label endless
earned them like 150 K 20 milli I mean
is that like commendable though is it I
don't like people say finesse as if it's
like a positive thing I like is that
like when you're like when you do a deal
with someone like the deals are
structure where it's like we'll do three
albums because we believe that you're on
with this trajectory well you where
you'll and we'll help you get there but
then you know when someone is like so
poppin I guess or whatever where they're
like okay well I could just do this
independently and like Def Jam doesn't
have to take all these royalties and
they pull something off like that and
basically scam a business out of that
not that I'm on the business on them on
like label side or like corporation side
at all balaiah
that's the reason why people do deals
like this yeah I mean I think isn't it
like kind of just like scamming someone
out of like you'll never do business
with these people ever again no and I
think where I feel everyone else in the
music industry is now like well now that
he needs it but like he's the one of the
only people in that situation where like
he can do that sort of thing which I
guess makes him
like a legend yeah I mean I think what's
commendable about it is that he I don't
know I could maybe it's not commendable
but I understand that if you signed to a
label and they put you on the back
burner he signed an onine bro and that
that whole thing was in 2016
seven [ __ ] years in seven years he
only got enough steam to put out one
[ __ ] album I don't I don't blame him
for being like you're gonna do what now
you're gonna give me the money give me a
chance to run away
cool [ __ ] you guys yeah yeah I don't
blame him and you hear that [ __ ] from
artists all the time oh yeah they signed
to a label and totally they don't do
anything for him yeah so or labels
[ __ ] people like like little Lucifer
oh yeah wait what happened with that
release music is that is that what we
wanted to release me yeah he's like
wanted to release his album forever and
they just like cuz his streaming numbers
are too big on his last album so they're
just like delaying the [ __ ] and I'm
pretty sure it's like completely done
and so he has to like he's forced like
leak his own music basically which
nobody makes money from is that why he's
retired I think so I mean I think like
you know him he's one of the first
people to come to mind but it's also
like other artists that are just like
just totally like their label is in
control of everything and they're like
as a creative person you like I wanted
to [ __ ] get this [ __ ] out yeah I made
this [ __ ] it's about my life right now
yeah so people should be hearing this
and the labels are like nope is like
this doesn't make sense on a business
level it's just man man yeah if you got
your own platform just really there's no
there's no reason to that's gonna be so
frustrating man to be under a contract
that you signed you know six years ago
and you were just starting out because
you had no idea what the [ __ ] would
happen it's probably only cool when
you're like a really big artist does
they give you all the steam they're
plugging your [ __ ] everywhere they're
making sure you're getting all that play
and all that press they're really
they're all those tools that a label
offers it probably comes out in the
nicest way that's what I'm saying
yeah but they have for everyone else
yeah sucks dick so is it commendable I
mean yeah you could definitely argue
it's a scam but that's that's what a
finesse is a finish I know finesse is
like used in a positive cause it's not a
positive
connotation but you know that that's but
yeah I mean yeah I don't know if I look
at finesse is like you used that word
when it's when it's deserved yeah you
know he did this to me something an
estimate of that kind of [ __ ] yeah I
mean if you if you outsmarted all of
these label execs then yeah it's a
finesse yeah for sure but like I'm sure
none of them are sitting there being
like [ __ ] we got 15 million bucks that
this dude just like finesse out of our
company like that's our jobs on one [ __ ]
like that yeah okay not that I'm
defending [ __ ] the other label shitty
like exactly like that but because I
know they can suck ass but I mean but
this is crazy
[Music]